thanks richard for that nice
introduction
uh it's really a pleasure for me to be
with your you here today
i'm going to talk about our preemptive
pharmacogenomics program
here in pittsburgh and specifically
how we're leveraging a simple uh
demonstration project an early
implementation into where we think
the field is going which is large-scale
implementation projects
to understand a little bit about that
you need to understand a little bit
about
how the environment here is at our
institution
so university of pittsburgh and
university of pittsburgh medical center
upmc
is really a unique environment to test
out
these new innovative ways of practice
specifically because upmsc is a very
large integrated
payer provided delivery and financing
system or idfs
and we have a large number of hospitals
clinics
and providers in close partnership with
the university of pittsburgh
and interestingly a payer we have an
integrated payer at upmc health plan
as well as an innovation center a
venture wing that does interpret
entrepreneurial and business enterprise
investments so from end to end
we have an entire environment here in
pittsburgh
to create this learning system to be
able to deploy innovative models of care
and importantly to advance new uh
delivery models
for precision medicine
this is really spearheaded by three main
groups within our medical center
the institute for precision medicine the
clinical
translational science institute and then
we're one of the
leading recruitment centers for the all
of us program here in pennsylvania
so precision medicine is really
something that's at the forefront of our
institution
and you can see here in the map that our
footprint
extends all the way from western
pennsylvania into ohio
all the way into upstate new york and
down into
northern maryland we have a large number
of provider
and and payers involved as i mentioned
before
not only our health system payer but
also
other commercial payers as well as
government payers
a large number of patients so as greater
than 4 million lives
40 hospitals and you can see here on the
slides and numbers of
physicians so when we think about a
deployment we have to think about all
these groups we have to think about how
we get
our new interventions made across our
system across
multiple sites multiple different
practice models
and then be able to capture the data and
make sure we're able to efficiently
deploy
so start this out was our first
implementation project
that was launched back in 2014 and like
many institutions really focused on
pharmacogenomics
we started in the cardiac
catheterization lab of our
flagship hospital upmc presbyterian
hospital
we deployed a single gene test that was
designed to
help us tailor anti-platelet medication
after
percutaneous coronary interventions or
pcis
so this is our press release from back
in 2015 when we launched
and it was a clinical program it was a
program in which all patients
that came into our health system with a
particular
diagnosis that were to receive a class
of medications would receive
a test automatically and those results
would be
used to inform care the design of this
is really important
this is how we started we first started
thinking about
well should this be a research or a
clinical program and in order to answer
that question
we started thinking about the potential
value proposition
now this is unique because we did it at
the forefront
because we are this payer provider model
we care very much about not only the
clinical utility that we think we could
bring but also the economics
and the return on investment so these
are not the actual calculations but it's
pretty close to what we predicted
to adding on pharmacogenomics to our
current strategy
and try to see if it would impact
potentially the financial modeling for
our institution
to decide how big and how wide of
intervention we want to start off with
now from there we had to develop our
make available testing
and for this particular project we
selected to develop on-site testing
specifically because we needed to have a
fast turnaround
at the time in which we were thinking
about deploying we had
a test that was being sent off site and
it would have been five to seven days
for us to return those test results
which simply was not feasible so we
brought testing on site
we clear validated panel in our calculab
and we reduced that turnaround time to
approximately 24 hours
we had to develop new clinical protocols
and for that we leaned heavily upon new
guidelines at the time that had been
released
from the clinical pharmacogenetics
implementation consortium
and you can see those of you who are
implemented this is a
very similar to what you find in that
particular publication
but we had recommendations to tailor
anti-platelet use depending on when a
patient was a
poor metabolizer or an enemy metabolizer
specifically
we had to think very creatively about
the informatics in our particular
institution we have
both epic and cerner so we get to do
this twice
in both ehr systems so that was a
significant lift and thinking about how
we wanted to deploy
clinical decision support particularly
and then we decided very early on that
we need to make sure we had
discrete results we had results that
were
fed into our ehr systems that were able
to trigger
decision support specifically on the
individual
phenotypes we would of course have a pdf
report came along with it as well
but it was really those discrete results
in the harmonization of those results
that was really important
for getting that clinical decision
support enabled on top of it within the
ehrs
we had an education system with test to
learn to be able to train our frontline
providers
through ce oriented programs and point
of care programs
and then we were most importantly able
to collect the phenotype results the
actual outcomes
within our registry and put all together
within the genomics data warehouse
so this is a very small screenshot but
in terms of our decision support we did
have decision support that fired for any
intermediate metabolizers as well as
poor metabolizers who are
either currently or receiving a to
receive
clopidogrel that would recommend
alternative therapy which was
presta girl or tech aggregator at our
institution
and then we spun up brand new
pharmacists led services
so pharmacists at our institution
respond to every
test with a brief note that helps direct
care and reaches out
to the provider whether the patient's in
or outside the hospital
about any potential changes in
prescribing
so this program has been tremendously
successful you can see here that we're
at the time we're at 2900 test results
and this day we're just over three
thousand
and you can see our predicted phenotype
reports were very similar to what you
would expect by population frequencies
uh approximately 28 or 29 of our
patients
altogether how to carry a loss of
function variance and we look at the
medications they were prescribing
about 20 percent of them had an
actionable result overall
that would necessarily a change in
medication management
so those are facilitated again by our
pharmacist led services
our console notes and working through
regular uh traditional changes
and recommendations once those test
results came back
so fast forward a number of years and we
were very fortunate to partner with
seven other institutions within the
nih's
implementation network called ignite
and this is a publication many of you
may have seen already that was a
pragmatic clinical trial
that combined the outcomes for major
adverse cardiac events among these seven
institutions
and this kaplan-meier chart shows that
uh patients that
were loss of function carriers that were
had remained on clopidogrel for whatever
reason
had a statistically significant
difference of
the composite for magic for mace for
death mi and stroke
that was higher than patients that were
converted to an alternative
and there was no difference between the
gray line the non-loss of function
carrier
and those were switched so this is
exactly what you want to see in a
precision medicine project a
pharmacogenomics project
that shows if we're able to tailor
prescribing we can get to an outcome
that's no different
from a patient that may not be carrying
this loss of function variance
so we're really excited by this and this
network has gone on in work that was led
by
uh nida limdy at uab to be able to do
the
economic modeling so i urge you to read
this paper that just came out last year
or earlier this year that describes the
economic and the cost modeling
downstream of this
with a sensitivity analysis that goes
through different costs of testing
as well as different deployment models
to recommend
that a gen type guided strategy may be
superior to conventional approaches
so this was a very successful deployment
our institution and institution was
excited about the opportunities for
sort of spearheading our genomic
programs specifically through
pharmacogenomics and now to our other
hospitals and other clinics now at this
time we were also very aware of that
there were many other gene drug pairs
that we were excited about deploying
but sort of had to think through well do
we want to do this
again and again with individual gene
drug pairs
so this is a common thought that i think
many institutions
and practice sites in the field are
dealing with is whether to run
individual single gene tests
and implement them that way as gene drug
pairs or think more broadly about
whether we should be considering panel
based testing
so our institution and our research
group started doing analyses to
determine whether
it made sense to jump to a preemptive
model we would get results
well in advance of needing them and then
for many genes that may have
gene drug associated recommendations and
guidelines
in order to be much more strategic about
taking care of all of our patients
that were in our practice model and
within the upmc
system
so we started looking at our data from
our existing project first and said
well if we got these sepsis 19 data
results back
were they useful to be reused and we
always talk about
germline results which is 2c19 is a
germline test of course
being potentially reusable not only for
the same medication again but also for
any other medication
that might be going through the similar
pathway so we conducted an analysis on
the left
that shows that there were many patients
that had gone on to receive
in just a six month period another
medication that went through the same
pathway
and would have a interruptive clinical
decision support alert
that recommended change in therapy now
these are often proton pump inhibitors
or antidepressants
that would recommend an alternative path
if we had these genetic tests on
file meaning that the result was not
only useful for the original indication
but also for subsequent tests and
subsequent drug prescribing
if you could just make sure that test
result was available to the downstream
provider
now the same same same type of analysis
was just done on a broader scale
you can see the n being much larger
within the
ignite pharmacogenomics working group
and this was a study led by amber
betelges
in maryland that was also recently
published that show
similar data in that about half of the
patients
received a subsequent sip 2c19 substrate
or a medication and went through the
same pathway
and then a large proportion of those
actually had a gene drug interaction
where they had a phenotype
that suggests that an intervention would
need to be made based on
that predicted phenotype and test result
again emphasizing these results
are likely to be reusable even with a
single gene test
now as we think more broadly we
conducted an analysis
of much larger data sets in the first
graph at the top there the table
shows our data from a publication
several years back
we looked at 73 million patients and
looked at the incident use
of drugs that have pharmacogenomic
guidance and it was extremely high
right around the same 50 percent
suggests that
patients that were in these age groups
listed at a very high frequency of being
prescribed these medications
in a general payer landscape again this
is sort of
cms data predominantly to be able to
um show that these relatively usable if
we had pharmacogenomic tests on file
and then recently a new study by uh sony
dutasius group at penn
and others pulled together results
looking at
a similar analysis in a veteran
population
and show that 99 carried at least one
actual variance
and that there was a high incidence of
cpic a drugs being prescribed in a six
year period
again emphasizing there is likely
utility in a
u.s veteran population for having these
data
on file and a large number of patients
and that potentially could be used
in a relatively short time horizon this
is six years
but you can imagine in the va system
where patients are seen
continuously for for quite some time
that these data would have increasing
value
as patients came back into the health
system and were prescribed
new medications so in in our in our
analysis thinking back at our own health
system seeing this type of data made us
think
well do we want to do individual gene
drug deployments or do we want to think
more broadly
and the solution was definitely the
latter
so we formed a new partnership and it
really innovative
academia health system industry
partnership you can see the groups
described here in
our publication that emphasized
the direction and the goals of this we
created their brand new pharmacogenomic
center of excellence in pittsburgh
by bringing together my group here in
pitt pharmacy in the school of pharmacy
at the university of pittsburgh
ctsi that i mentioned before this
research-based framework
that provides infrastructure across the
university the
institute for precision medicine leading
precision medicine programs
as well as uvmc clinical our brand new
genome center
the health plan as well as that
commercialization unit within upmc
and in partnership with thermo fisher
which was a certainly a leading
innovator in developing testing
solutions we brought this new
center of excellence to pittsburgh with
the goal of doing preemptive panel-based
testing in at least 150
000 patients and to be able to return
these results to
researchers and clinicians
so this is that model a patient would
come in
um or in this case actually um there
wouldn't be a patient they would be
a research uh participant so in this
case an individual
is interested in our study um they are
recruited
to join an institution of biorepository
and the results
uh from a pharmacogenomic panel that is
run
in a brand new cap clio lab
and it's all clinically validated within
our genome center
and the results end up being returned to
a clinical
i mean sorry to a research pipeline as
vcf so a common um
a genetic data format a varying call
file where we would merge that data with
pharmacogenomic test results
ehr data and claims data
to understand the relationships between
genotypes and phenotypes conduct new
analytics
and to do more novel based drug response
phenotyping
and understanding all the downstream
economic value to develop these economic
proof points we think are essential
to advance the field moving forward now
this panel is broad
it covers approximately 1200 genes
but we were not ready to return all of
those to clinical care after all
not all the results have clinical
guidelines
yet and because of that we selected and
curated the ones that we thought
were ready for clinical deployment and
actionability within a clinical
environment
so within our clinical pipeline we
brought forward 14 genes
and developed a pipeline a clinical
pipeline to be able to do allele
translation
phenotype assignment be able to report
discrete results
again to epic and cerner have a clia
based sign out
and then return those results to upmc
ehrs
services and to patients directly
through their myupmc
patient portal now again this is all
done in the cap clear lab
so essentially a traditional regular
clinical sign-off process
and it's elective meaning a patient that
signs the research consents
um is interested in being an individual
involved in research
would elect for return and these
individuals would get the results back
through regular clinical services
they would also contribute to research
by contributing their data into this
research pipeline
so the overall hypothesis is a primary
prediction of patient drug report
response phenotypes through
pharmaceuticals
will drive research engagement i'll get
people excited about participating in
research and our institution
uh by repository that it will drive cost
effective improvements in
medication outcomes again these economic
proof points we're all
looking for in terms of proving clinical
utility and then finally
new genetic phenotype discovery could be
able to look for
potentially rare variants in a very
large population and link it to
medication
outcomes as we have all the prescribing
data for these
patients
this is a photo from our genome center
and again this
new panel that we're deploying is
pharmacoscan a product of thermo fisher
scientific
it's a bell 1200 genes 4600 variants and
important includes a copy number
um variant assessment for uh
sip 2d6 as well as other genes on the
research side
those all end up going into research and
then the 14 genes i mentioned
are what will be returned when that
pathway is elected by these
individuals going through this research
project
on the clinical side these discrete
results flow into the electronic health
record again when elected
and patients receive the results for
their patient portal
and on the provider side we're doing a
lot with education to make sure that
providers know how to use this data we
know our pharmacists are many of them
are well trained and understand how to
use pharmacogenomic information
but we have a lot of providers across
our health system
and we really need to raise the bar and
extend education out to the providers
that may not be
as knowledgeable about deploying these
results in order to capture that return
on investment
so this means uh triggered interruptive
alerts where necessary
access to education wherever that needs
to be at the point of care
and then when necessary provide services
so that's pharmacist-led services
and directing patients into our new
primary care precision medicine clinic
that's a partnership between pharmacy
family medicine and genetic counselors
to be able to provide in-person or maybe
telemedicine nowadays
care directly to these patients
and we'll spend a little bit of time
talking specifically about the education
piece as i finish
up this education is really really
important again we have thousands of
providers that may not feel comfortable
in the surveys that have been published
across many institutions so that
that the providers are really eager to
provide these services
but don't have quite the confidence to
be able to do this
so we have an innovative education
program that's called test to learn
that allows providers to work with real
genetic data
in order to learn how to provide these
services and take care of the patients
using these new test results
so the unique part of this training is
that learners can go through personal
genomic testing so they can go through
the same testing
that their future patients will or
individuals that are participating in
this research will
and they'll be able to look at the
results and we have
a strong outcome data that showed both
objectively and subjectively that
performance goes up and this in our
early study was in a pharmd
curriculum in the school of pharmacy but
we see uh great data surrounding
efficacy and confidence of
providers using these data as well and
this program
has been so successful that we deployed
it in many other universities and health
systems across the country
uh through generous support of the folks
that you see below at the bottom of the
screen
so after education the the real engine
for return
on the return of investment on the
discovery side of things is
to uh estimate the return investment
just like we did with the clopidogrel
and the cath lab
to identify populations and draw circles
around them and be able to track them
moving forward
take that phenotype uh look for the
outcomes within their claims data and
their outcome data within ehrs or a
necessary additional data collection
and then pilot to measure those outcomes
with the therapy changes
and validate the model and then just
turn that circle around to develop
economic proof points on the research
side we think the data are not quite
ready
this is how we generate more data we
collect the genotypes measure the
phenotypes
and then to see whether there seems to
be an association that could potentially
move forward into our clinical
modeling so this is our our engine for
using
um and demonstrating clinical utility
finally in looking at those first few
patients that are involved in this new
pharmacogenomic center of excellence
project
we recruited just over 5000 patients to
dates
and again we did the same analysis to
determine whether taking medications and
to know whether the decision support we
have already written
for these gene drugs would fire on these
patients as we return results
and indeed that same percentage is there
again about 40 of our patients
uh are taking our one drug
at least where there is some alert that
would fire immediately
and you can see the decreasing
percentages but still
fairly large numbers that have been
exposed to many drugs and you can see
the numbers are very very high there
where there's a subset of population
that are on five or more medications um
that would potentially have an even more
value from this
so while khloe is there we're thanking
our entire team
to build a infrastructure in a
preemptive program
and even the demonstration project i
mentioned before it takes a large group
of folks
with a variety of expertise certainly a
multi-disciplinary team
from everything from pharmacogenomics
and pharmacy
to the areas we're deploying and all the
different institutes and groups i've
talked about
so i want to thank them and i want to
thank you for your attendance today and
i'd be happy to take any questions
thank you